all right chef for more on this let's
bring in texas department of public
safety's south texas region spokesperson
lieutenant chris oliveira's lieutenant
thank you for joining us it's always
great to talk with you i've spent a lot
of time with you down there in texas but
today is a particularly somber day at
sombra weekend how is dps handling this
latest news
good afternoon griffin of course great
to be with you and as you mentioned yes
you've been to the border numerous times
you've been with our men and women of
texas dps national guard border patrol
and you've seen the great work they're
doing day in and day out to be on those
front lines but what occurred of course
on friday with our national guard
soldiers very tragic this brave soldier
that's just a true example of bravery
and courage by going into that river
that dangerous river and trying to
rescue several immigrants that were
distressed and that's what our men and
women do day in and day out from border
patrol our dps troopers our national
guardsmen they risk their lives every
single day by being on those front lines
not only apprehending criminals and
seizing drugs but also performing these
rescue operations and it's a very
dangerous river just this month alone
there's been over 19 drownings in the
eagle pass area bill millusion reported
just this past week there was three in a
single day so it's very dangerous but
again you know our men and women risked
their lives every single day
to go into this river to rescue
immigrants that are already violating
federal law but nonetheless they still
regardless put that aside and they go in
there rescue these people that are
coming across because that's what
they're that's what they're there for
they're there to provide a service and
also not only that but to protect the
state of texas
lieutenant in your opinion was this
avoidable could this have been prevented
in some way
you know griff it's kind of hard to say
because of course you know that's when
we're on the front lines regardless if
it's a national guardsman a border
patrol
agent or even a dps trooper
they have a split second decision to
make that decision to go into that river
and perform these rescue operations
whether it be a river whether it be out
in the mountains in west texas uh there
is really no way to determine if this
could have been avoidable now we do know
of course for a fact that if there was
more effective water policies that will
reduce the number of illegal immigrants
coming across that dangerous river but
again we're going to continue seeing the
flow of every immigrants coming across
uh bill just reported there earlier that
there's still immigrants coming across
that dangerous river knowing that
there's been drownings within this past
week alone but again it's just very
difficult to put into words about what
took place and again just great work by
our men and women and right now we are
using every resource at our disposal
from u.s border patrol texas game
wardens our state dive team uh military
department right now performing search
and rescue operations uh to rescue this
soldier and of course we want to extend
our prayers on behalf of the texas
department of public safety to that
soldier to the family and all those
first responders that are out there on
the front lines every day day in and day
out away from their families risking
their lives to protect texas and the
entire country
and let's just look quickly if we can
lieutenant at the numbers the month of
march numbers
221 thousand three 303 apprehensions
compared to this time last year 173
277 we didn't hit 200 000 until july
last year and last year was a record
unprecedented number of apprehensions
when you hear tom holman in the report
before us with bill's report talking
about the border being out of control
how do you see it
is it out of control well
well grip it is because border agents
right now they're just tied up they're
overwhelmed with the constant processing
they're having to do because the surge
of illegal immigrants coming across just
for this fiscal year alone for the first
six months over 1.2 million encounters
that's not even including the over 300
000 known godaways but that is why you
know governor abbott stepped in from the
very beginning and texas is taking on
president actually right now with
operation lone star and deploying
additional resources additional state
assets to the border to help our federal
partners just what we've been able to do
since the start of operation lone star
making over fourteen thousand criminal
arrests out of that nearly twelve
thousand of those felony arrests of
course over thirty eight hundred couple
of trespass arrests those are the
illegal immigrants that are traversing
and circumventing the checkpoints on
private ranches and also most
importantly over 300 million lethal
doses that have been seized in the state
of texas so we are trying to gain
operation control of this border the
state of texas is that's why we have a
proactive plan in place and try to
prevent
what's what's to come in may with these
caravans the thousands of immigrants
that are waiting in mexico we do not
want to see we want to prevent what took
place in del rio last year with the
haitians unless we are we are constantly
involving border operations with our
federal partners also with our
international partners as well
do you need a little more just in the 30
seconds we've got is there more that
your federal partners not the border
patrol but the white house and the
lawmakers in washington could be doing
to help you
well of course i mean they need to take
more effective strategies have a
comprehensive immigration reform
also do not cancel title 42 and if you
are going to cancel title 42 have an
effective strategy in place so we don't
see this mass flow of immigrants coming
across and also work with other local
partners as well and also congressional
partners and they come together and have
a plan in place and that's why again
because of that state of texas has to
continue stepping in and try to develop
strategies to help secure the border and
help our federal partners
well we shall be watching if they have
that plan in place my sources from
traveling in mexico a caravan has
already started it's not a huge one but
it started in tapachula it made its way
to wheatla yesterday that's a
traditional bath and the last one i
followed ended up in eagle pass
lieutenant chris oliveiras thank you for
taking time sir
thank you graham stay safe out there